you wanted to land in that person's
inbox the first thing we need is
deliverability with the email so a CRM
system ATS when you put an attachment on
it it's most likely going to go into
spam or promotions so the number one tip
that I would give to everyone is make
sure it's just black and white text okay
there's no hyperlinks there's no
signatures on the email so it looks like
it's just a personal email from James
decision so that gives it a probably a
80 chance to get through all of the spam
filters and funnels to make sure it
lands in the inbox then it's all about
the follow-up procedures and it's all
about timing to catch them at a time
when someone's handed in the notice
they've just had new budget to open out
a wall you have to be front of mind okay